maintenant comment relancer l'économie
dans une situation sanitaire contrôler
c'est le titre d'une conférence
prononcée par le docteur carl maes chef
de la division des maladies infectieuses
à l'hôpital général juif de montréal
c'était ce midi devant la chambre de
commerce du montréal métropolitain
il est notre invité ce soir dr weiss
bonsoir vous a beaucoup vu à notre
antenne au cours de la dernière année
mais c'est une première raison
économistes un plaisir de vous
accueillir ce soir c'est clair que la
vaccination c'est la sortie
la sortie de crise vous l'avais répété
encore ce midi vous avez parlé d'israël
du royaume uni notamment où on est à 50
60 % de gens qui ont au moins une dose
de vaccin et on voit l'ouverture qui est
en cours là bas est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à la même chose chez nous
mais je l'espère sincèrement
donc vous l'avez bien souligné il ya une
seule façon de sortir de cette pandémie
au moins d'eau calment c'est de vacciner
la population à un niveau qui soit assez
élevée pour redonner confiance à pouvoir
faire des choses de la vie de tous les
jours sans risque de contamination
importante et surtout sans risque de
contamination de la population à risque
il faut revenir à la base de tout on a
tous fermés pour une raison principale
c'est pour protéger le système de santé
parce que les personnes âgées des
personnes à risque était susceptible de
tomber très malade d'être hospitalisé
tel est aux soins intensifs et donc ça
bloquer le fonctionnement du système de
santé pour tout le reste et le système
ne pourrait pas fonctionner de cette
manière là donc maintenant qu'on a
protégé ou qu'on commence à protéger la
population de meilleures façons ce qu'on
espère c'est de retourner à la vie
normale de tous les jours comme cela a
été fait dans d'autres pays
une fois qu'un certain pourcentage de la
population a reçu une dose de vaccin
alors le gouvernement semble travailler
sur un scénario de déconfinement comme
la saskatchewan c'est à dire une
première étape de réouverture de
l'économie à partir du moment que 70
pour cent soixante dix pour cent déjà de
40 ans et plus sont vaccinés et on
ferait ça trois semaines après est-ce
que c'est un bon scénario de réouverture
a votre avis il faut répondre
question de la façon suivante
premièrement il n'y a pas de recette
parfaite et miraculeuse qui nous dit la
science a démontré que si vous aviez 70%
ça fonctionne 65 et 75 signe donc déjà
on prend un certain risque mais depuis
le début de la tow vie dans le fait que
prend des risques
le deuxième point est important a
souligné ça doit être un contrat entre
d'une part le gouvernement mais aussi la
population c'est-à-dire le gouvernement
peut promettre des choses à la
population mais la population
contrepartie doit se faire vacciner
respecter les règles d'isolement de
garder des masques etc
quand ce sera nécessaire de le faire une
fois qu'on a dit ça ce qu'on sait c'est
que lorsqu'on a vacciné plus de 70% de
la population adulte et surtout plus de
90% de la population à risque que
l'impact de la colite dans la société à
ce moment-là et minimiser à son maximum
et encore une fois l'exemple d'israël
qui a vacciné plus de 90 % de sa
population adulte et surtout les
patients les plus âgés avec deux doses
qui a complètement rouvert le pays
quasiment sans masse sans rien et qui a
quasiment pas de cas ou très très peu
et lorsqu'ils surviennent c'est souvent
dans les populations à risque non
protégé donc donc ça démontre que avec
une ouverture complète de l'économie de
la société c'est même plus grand que
l'économie se serait l'aspect social
aspects des spectacles et ses 15 ans
n'avait une population très immunisé à
ce moment là vous pouvez avec une
certaine sécurité
je pense qu'on est aussi rendu à l'étape
où la population demande ce genre de
choses là parce que on un couvre feu
depuis longtemps on a des confinement
depuis longtemps et donc ça devient avec
l'arrivée de l'été et l'internât cité il
faut pas oublier aussi de voyager parce
que l'on parle du québec
mais c'est clair pour les québécois ne
voyageront pas l'extérieur du pays
donc ça va ça va garder les gens et ils
sont les gens est une espèce de soupape
de sécurité il faut enlever un peu de
vapeur pour que les gens puissent
continuer à adhérer au principe jusqu'à
quel point on peut rouvrir
on sait que ça prend les deux doses mais
jusqu'à quel point on peut rouvrir
l'économie après la première dose
écoutez c'est difficile de répondre à la
question mais je vous répondrais la
façon suivante c'est quand on dit
deux doses mais on a mis tout le monde
dans le même panier c'est à dire qu'on a
mis des personnes âgées en chcd chez qui
on sait qu'il faut de dons et de doses
rapprochés on a mis des gens qui sont
des gens avec des cancers qui reçoivent
des traitements chimiothérapie on a mis
des gens par exemple qui sont très
malades qui ont de la dialyse
alors ces gens là c'est des petites
proportions de la société mais qui ont
besoin de ces deux doses pour être
protégé maintenant c'est clair que si
vous êtes une jeune personne
travailleurs de la santé où n'importe
qui dans la société qui a 40 ans qui est
en pleine forme qui n'a aucune maladie
sous jacente qu'une dose va certainement
vous donner une protection temporaire on
s'entend mais une protection quand même
avant de recevoir une deuxième dose
donc il ya aussi un espace je vous
dirais d'apprentissage et de risque
calculée à prendre je vous dirais la
protection parfaite n'existe pas et
n'existera jamais même avec deux doses
et toute la population vaccinée
donc c'est une question de quel risque
on est prêt à prendre mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi apprendre à utiliser
par exemple des tests rapides de façon
plus intelligente dans le futur il
faudrait que c'est une combinaison de
facteurs qui vont nous permettre de
pouvoir retourner à une vie normale
certainement au québec au canada parce
qu'on parle pas encore de l'échelle
planétaire
est ce qu'il faut aller jusqu au
passeport vaccinale puis là je vais plus
loin que les voyages même pour
réintégrer certaines activités de notre
de notre vie c'est un choix que certains
pays ont fait qui semble bien
fonctionner israël l'a fait le danemark
120 versa la chine semble faire d'écouté
c'est qui encore une fois un choix
société de toute façon on aura besoin
d'un passeport vaccinale pour voyager à
l'extérieur du pays sinon on va limiter
la capacité des canadiens à l'est dans
beaucoup de pays qui vont nous l'exigé
de toute façon et sur lequel on n'aura
rien à dire une fois qu'on a dit ça
bon ça devient un débat de société et un
débat d'éthique mais le fait d'avoir un
passeport vaccinale avec ce que ça
implique qu est ce que ça comporte
d'un point de vue aussi cybersécurité il
faudra que ce soit bien fait bien
respecté c'est certainement un outil
supplémentaire pour favoriser je vous
dirais un retour à la vie normale pour
ceux qui ont eu le vaccin pour peut-être
favorisé la vaccination chez des gens
qui sont hésitants pas con
la vaccination mais hésitant et qui vont
finir par l'accepter une fois qu'ils
auront je vous dirai plus de sécurité de
sens de sécurité à recevoir des vaccins
mais a donc ça peut être un outil très
intéressant à mettre en place pour
retourner à une vie normale
d'ailleurs on aura l'exemple de pays qui
le remplace depuis un bout de temps et
on verra l'impact que c'est ce passeport
vaccinale aura sur le retour à une vie
économique sociale culturelle normal
débat important et intéressant dr weiss
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir on a
fait très plaisir
bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit